[Música]
vamos al repaso de las noticias
económicas con Daniela Blandón Daniela
saludo nuevamente para usted Hola Ángela
y vamos a continuar esta vez vamos a
iniciar con las noticias desde
California con miles de trabajadores
hoteleros que están en huelga estamos en
el inicio del verano además Daniela
claro no es un buen momento para que
entrenen o el gasto deben pensar sus
empleadores pues United local Eleven
representa unos 15.000 trabajadores
incluidos a más de llaves en lavaplatos
cocineros meseros también botones o
recepcionistas de más de 60 hoteles en
los condados de Los Ángeles y de Orange
muchos de ellos son hoteles de lujo que
por estos días están abarrotados de
gente el sindicato declaró el domingo lo
que se considera desde ya una de las
huelgas más grandes que hate afectado a
la industria hotelera en la historia
reciente de Estados Unidos esta disputa
laboral tiene varios componentes clave
primero como lo decíamos este pleno
apogeo del festivo veraniego del 4 de
julio también se superpone la vuelta de
guionistas de Hollywood que hoy comienza
su tercer mes y ocurre también cuando la
Florida se prepara para acoger no
solamente el mundial de fútbol de 2026
que lo cogerá Pues todo Estados Unidos y
México y Canadá sino también los Juegos
Olímpicos y paralímpicos de 2028 cada
gremio desde luego tiene sus propias
exigencias pero en lo que coinciden
ambos casos tanto guionistas como los
trabajadores de los hoteles es que el
alto costo de vida en California es
insostenible
desde la pandemia empezaron a despedir
gente hemos tenido mucha carga de
trabajo encima antes eran 800 empleados
Ahora somos 500 a veces terminó haciendo
el trabajo de dos o tres personas los
trabajadores el hotel tienen que mudarse
cada vez más lejos para viajar a la
ciudad lo que obliga a conducir dos o
tres horas hicimos una encuesta nuestros
miembros y el 53% de los que
respondieron dijeron que tenían que
mudarse o que se mudarán en los próximos
cinco años debido al aumento del costo
de la vivienda
no trabaja para tener calidad de vida y
vivir a dos o tres horas del trabajo no
le da calidad de vida a nadie y la
propiedad raíz en California está
subiendo bastante bueno y además todo
agravado por las celebraciones del 4 de
julio cuando se espera muchísima
afluencia de personas Mejor dicho una
receta del caos Así es vamos a cambiar
de tema vamos ahora a hablar de Francia
el gobierno anunció medidas para los
comerciantes afectados por las protestas
pues es el ministro de economía y
finanzas Bruno reveló el fin de semana
que más de 700 empresas han sido
Víctimas de ataques y daños desde el
inicio de los disturbios el martes por
la noche concretamente más de 450
comercios y 250 sucursales bancarias han
sido asaltados saqueados y algunos
quemados por completo tiendas de moda y
artículos deportivos también en cadenas
de comidas rápidas están entre los
negocios perjudicados por eso se ha
propuesto una serie de medidas para
ayudar a estos comerciantes en primer
lugar el ministro pidió a las
aseguradoras que aceleren las
indemnizaciones y también que reduzcan
los deducibles también solicitó a los
bancos una mayor flexibilidad en los
plazos de pago y anunció un posible
aplazamiento del pago de cargas sociales
y de impuestos finalmente habrá una
semana de prórroga de las rebajas
iniciadas hace apenas unos días todo
esto como parte de la agitada temporada
de verano otro sitio en donde en ese
momento no es tan buena negocio es las
protestas no Y sobre todo que pues
Imagínese usted todas las personas que
están replanteándose si deberían
Cancelar su viaje a Francia o si
deberían moverse de Ciudad entonces
bueno cerrando ese tema que está
complicado también vamos a hablar ahora
de la secretaria del tesoro que esta
semana va a estar en China Janet yelen
va a estar en territorio chino desde el
próximo jueves seis de mayo hasta el
domingo una visita que se da apenas
semanas después de que también lo
hiciera el secretario de estado Anthony
blinken y en momentos en que las
relaciones comerciales están muy tensas
con prohibiciones de lado y lado para
empresas sobre todo del sector de la
tecnología los detalles los tiene
nuestro corresponsal en Beijing Adrián
Fonsi
Beijing recibirá esta semana a Janet
yelen la secretaria del tesoro en el
último intento de ambos países por
reconducir sus relaciones y por
encontrar un marco de entendimiento
mínimo en nuestra nuestra previsto que
lleguen durante sus cuatro días aquí en
Beijing se reúna con el presidente chino
pero a cambio sí podrá conocer al nuevo
equipo al frente de la economía nacional
salió después de la última remodelación
y de hablar con la con representantes de
la clase empresarial estadounidense aquí
en China yelen ha defendido durante
mucho tiempo la cooperación con china en
áreas globales como el cambio climático
y se ha mostrado en contra del
desacoplamiento económico a cambio ha
señalado áreas de preocupación en las
que el entendimiento será más difícil
como los derechos humanos o las
políticas comerciales este será el
segundo viaje de un alto cargo
estadounidense a Beijing en menos de un
mes después del de Anthony blinken el
secretario de estado a que el viaje que
china pospuso durante más de cuatro
meses y medio por el incidente del globo
acabó con la satisfacción de todas las
partes pero el presidente estadounidense
Joe biden arruinó el clima en apenas un
día al llamar dictador así sin pin
es quizá por eso por lo que las
expectativas aquí en China son bastante
bajas ante esta nueva visita el viaje ha
merecido una escasísima atención en los
medios a cambio el global Times un
diario ultranacionalista hoy advertía
contra los políticos estadounidenses que
han cambiado el concepto de
desacoplamiento por otro más ligero como
es el de reducción de riesgos con china
dice el diario que esos dos conceptos
encierran la misma realidad es decir
sanciones económicas a las empresas
chinas y cortar Los lazos económicos y
ya por esta hora podemos empezar a
hablar de indicadores Claro porque acaba
de abrir Wall Street después de un muy
buen cierre trimestral el viernes pasado
la bolsa de Nueva York que inició mixto
con ganancias mixtas con ganancias en el
índice nasdaq impulsadas por tesla Y es
que la compañía de autos de lujo de
propiedad de elon musk reportó entregas
récord de vehículos en el segundo
trimestre y su acción subía casi un 7%
en operaciones previas a la apertura del
mercado vamos ahora hacia donde las
bolsas cerraron con repunte en China el
gobierno anunció subsidios para las
empresas que emplean a personas de 16 a
24 años o graduados que hayan estado
desempleados durante dos años en Japón
el Gen cayó a mínimos de casi 8 meses
frente al Dólar por rumores que hay
entre los inversionistas acerca de una
posible intervención del Mercado de
Divisas y el índice de referencia de
Pakistán registró su mayor salto de un
solo día en 15 años ganó casi 6% en la
primera sesión de negociación esto
después de que el país obtuviera un
acuerdo de financiación del fondo
monetario internacional por tres mil
millones de dólares y vamos a cerrar en
Europa a punto del cierre de las
acciones subieron con excepción de
Alemania ya que hubo datos adicionales
sobre un débil crecimiento en China Y
eso apoya las esperanzas de que habrá un
estímulo político en ese país y pues por
supuesto eso golpea todas las bolsas
Daniela Muchísimas gracias Aquí nos
vemos mañana con más información
económica como siempre un placer así es